[موسيقى
] أجنبية هنا في نيو مكسيكو بدون الفلفل الحار في
مكان ما يشعر
الناس بالحيرة تمامًا لدرجة أننا
نأكل الكثير من الفلفل الحار هنا ، أعني
أنه حقًا جزء من كل وجبة تقريبًا كل يوم
يغير حياة الناس سيأتي الناس إلى
هنا ويقولون إنني أشم رائحتها  هذه
الرائحة منذ وصولي إلى هنا ، ولكن
بمجرد شم
رائحتها وشرائها ، تذوقوها ، فإنهم مرتبطون
بها ، فهم يحبونها في
الواقع ، أصدرت نيو مكسيكو
تشريعات لحماية تشيليزنا ، لذا
لا يمكنك الحصول على فلفل حار على طريقة نيو مكسيكو
أو  نيو مكسيكو تشيلي خارج ولايتنا في
أي وقت تأخذ فيه على سبيل المثال
فلفل حار أخضر وتأخذ هذه البذور
وتزرعها خارج الولاية ، فهي ليست
فلفل حار أخضر من نيو مكسيكو ، مثلها مثل
الفرنسيين والحرب هي الأرض
ونكهة  الأرض
موجودة في الطعام ،
نحن الولاية الوحيدة في الجنوب الغربي
التي تحتوي على اللونين الأحمر والأخضر وهي
مكسيكية جديدة بشكل فريد وهذا
ما يميزنا
كثيرًا بين
تشيلي أخضر من نيو مكسيكو وأحمر نيو مكسيكو
لا علاقة للفلفل الحار بالألوان
في مرحلة النضج ، فالعنب ، والآخر زبيب ،
كما تعلم ، لقد طرحت
سؤالًا مثيرًا للاهتمام حقًا في وقت سابق حول الأحمر
أو الأخضر لأن هذا هو
سؤال الحالة ، إليك مقولة
الفلفل الأخضر بينما نتحرك هنا ولكن أحمر
الفلفل الحار بينما
نبقى في مرحلة نضج الفلفل الحار بالنسبة
لي موسمي جدًا عندما يكون الجو باردًا
بالخارج ، لا أستطيع الحصول على ما يكفي من اللون الأحمر ولا
يمكن أن يكون الجو حارًا بدرجة كافية خلال الصيف
والخريف ، أريد اللون الأخضر لأن هذا كل
ما تشتمه وهذا  هي الرائحة
التي بالنسبة لي هي رائحة المنزل ، فأنا أحب
الفلفل الأخضر ، لكنني نوع من أه مدللة
مع ذلك ، فأنا أحبها فقط محمصة طازجة
وليست خارج الثلاجة قبل
التبريد كان الفلفل الأخضر حدثًا خاصًا ،
إنه وقت معين من  السنة
التي تنضج فيها لا تزال خضراء ولكنها
ناضجة بما يكفي لتناول الطعام لم تتحول إلى اللون
الأحمر ولكن الفلفل الأحمر ، تلك السلاسل التي
تراها معلقة بشكل زخرفي من المباني في
الوقت الحاضر أو ​​في الواقع الطريقة التي تجفف
بها الفلفل الأحمر والهنكين  g في هذا الشكل
يبقيه بعيدًا عن الأرض ويبقيه جافًا ، فهو
يبقي الفئران بعيدًا عنه حتى
لا تتمكن القوارض من الوصول إليه ، فهو مزخرف في الغالب
الآن ، ولكن إذا كنت تريد العودة لفترة طويلة بما يكفي
، فسيكون لكل منزل في الوادي
ديوك فلفل أحمر معلقة  من كل فيجا
يحصلون على إمداداتهم الشتوية ،
هذا هو صوت افتتاح بوابات الجنة ،
أمارس مكيالين من
الفلفل الحار سنويًا يبلغ وزنهما 100 رطل
وهذا ما أعرفه تمامًا في المنزل ،
لذلك سنستخدم الفلفل الحار وسنقوم بذلك.
املأها ، فتقطعها إلى شرائح
وتضعها على الهامبرغر ، ضعها على شطيرة ديك رومي ،
ضعها في خبز التورتيلا وصنع
بوريتو ، أعني أنها هي فقط
بالنسبة لي ، كل شيء
يختتم في حب غير مشروط يختتم بالفلفل الحار
[موسيقى]